all hell is breaking loose this spring
break authorities in Miami Beach
declaring a state of emergency and
imposing a curfew there after two deadly
shootings but the lockdown still didn't
stop the Mayhem shops got trashed and
Rowdy partygoers were seen jumping on
cars fights have been breaking out on
the streets and on the beach the Miami
Beach mayor has had enough of the chaos
we don't want spring break we don't ask
for it we endure it we have an enormous
police presence and the two shootings
that you referred to there were police
on the scene within seconds arrests were
made within minutes but it's still not
deterring the misbehavior
Jesse what do you think has changed in
the culture of spring break because it
used to be the big fear was alcohol
poisoning right that parents were afraid
their kids would just drink too much and
have to go to the hospital this is you
end up dead some of the violence looks
gang or drug related that one shooting
looked targeted to me it's like a point
blank shot to the head and then they put
him down on the ground with extra shots
there was something going on there Miami
Beach is a new destination it was never
that when I was growing up it was the
Fort Lauderdale was Daytona Panama City
so now Miami Beach has a real problem
and they're just going to ruin it for
everybody no one else is going to go to
Miami Beach if people are just lying in
a pool of blood so they're going to ban
it there was another I believe it was on
the west coast a couple years back after
some of the Hannity exposes one of the
Mayors was like we've had enough we're
absolutely shutting down but they
migrate to another place they'll either
go to Texas they'll go to different uh
side of the the peninsula but you just
have to stop attracting so much heat
when you're out there past midnight with
weapons or you're on the beach with
boxing gloves in unsanctioned events
you're drawing too much attention to
yourself and you don't want that much
police presence you want to do it under
the radar
you're giving advice I am they listen to
me yes they do the kids Greg do you
think it would it's possible to ban
spring break or make a dent in the
people are still going to Mexico with
the warnings about right the kidnapping
and it's amazing I didn't even know this
was happening you know what I'm you know
it's like we have it's like maybe it's
reassuring that we could have a we could
have war and crime and yet nothing gets
in the way of a good time for college
kids they don't give a damn they're
willing to spend their parents money uh
spring break was hell without this it
never looks like fun to me it's like and
it's weird who needs the break why do
students need break to go from playing
beer pong at ASU to playing beer pong in
Miami I mean their parents deserve the
spring break not them let them do the
jello shots not these losers I think
they need to have to come up with a new
spring break you know something that's
different maybe it needs a little more
risk a little more danger my spring
break like all good Spring Breaks have
bad memories did you notice that like I
remember when I was in Mazatlan uh a
local told me to go go me and my three
buddies to go to this bar and didn't
tell us it was a gay bar so we were like
18 years old sitting there drinking
Coronas out of a bucket and these guys
middle-aged guys were dancing around us
and I just thought it was a custom and
you stayed all night long I ended up I
didn't have to pay one night for my
hotel room
Dana what do you think I think that kids
should really listen to that that's nice
I mean that is really great about the
other thing that's happening in Miami
right now is the Miami open is going on
and Novak Djokovic is not allowed to
come in and play because of the stupid
coven rules and yet the Spring Breakers
are bringing guns to the party and they
have They confiscated 70 guns already
and I felt for the mayor today because
the businesses are mad at him because
they don't want to have a curfew at
midnight because that's when people are
making all the money into the wee hours
of the morning but he said you have to
have Law and Order so they're in trouble
I also noticed you know the Mexicans are
now Mexican president and his government
are paying a PR firm to try to deflect
blame about the fentanyl crisis from
them oh good and saying that Americans
don't hug their children enough and
that's why this is happening they could
have the cartels PR person maybe help
out with that yeah they don't they don't
hug their kids enough and therefore they
need Fentanyl and then they die it's
their fault exactly you know I think
that we're all making an assumption and
we're all assuming that these are
college kids on Spring break I've been
down in Miami I think it was two years
ago I don't believe a lot of them are on
spring break I think there are a lot of
young people you know maybe not so young
maybe not College age who go down there
just for trouble just to fight just to
show their Wares or whatever it is and
you know we shouldn't be so oh these are
kids you know just blowing off steam
getting drunk anymore that's not what
this is this is anarchy and Chaos 70
guns in one week in one city and two
dead I can't even imagine the number of
rapes the number of overdoses uh the
number of of people that have been
involved in assaults that they can't
even remember and I think that as
between business and Law and Order
you've got to take the side of Law and
Order because without it there will be
no business yeah I wonder Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
I know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now